do you want to announce the name of this
tune Stephen Lynch yeah well it's called
time machine because I was thinking
about how people are always talking
about like would you go back in time and
kill baby Hitler that's like a
philosophical query yeah sure molest
them and of course you would yeah yeah
that would be the first thing everybody
I would do but then then what would you
do right so that's kind of what I was
thinking with this
[Music]
guess what would be peachy keen a time
machine
yes got me thinking imagine all you
could do with it like killing baby
Hitler and save the world from sinking
that's great but wait
I've got other ideas if you know what I
mean so hop in let's begin
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] up with this time
machine
[Music]
step one baby Hitler's dead chopped off
his baby head and did a little dancing
step two set the hyperdrive to 1935 kill
baby Charlie Manson such fun I'm not
done 26 I got baby Edie I mean let's go
little kick it to slow's so many babies
to kill with this time machine baby
Harvey Weinstein in 52 nothing could
save you from the bullet that you face
to 84 I don't give a [ __ ] I'm killing
babies suck to save the world from
Facebook I'm saying he's a spy baby
Cosby's bottle was straightening then
shine Pol Pot but I got there late so he
died as a team
[Music]
and the guy who invented the leaf blower
I'm gonna do
that one slow
oh hell no what I cannot mention coz of
the Secret Service
but I think you
baby timothy mcveigh boom I'll get him
in the womb before he does his first
crime up last baby robert e lee if he's
dead you see the cell phone tries the
first time I'm done we had fun and got
some terrible babies off of the scene
disagree then you're free to go kill
baby me with your time machine to kill
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]